sytem on the agenda is statement by the
vice-president of the Commission High
Representative of the Union for Foreign
Affairs and security policy situation in
the broader Middle East region including
the crisis in Iran Iraq and Lebanon I
remind you that it is possible to
request HDI and blue cards using both
the standard registration and the
electronic system instructions are
available at the entrance of the
hemicycle for blue card requests though
they are accepted only after the round
of the speakers on behalf of the
political groups the debate will be open
by the vice-president of the Commission
High Representative of the Union for
Foreign Affairs and security policy mrs.
mogherini the floor is yours mr.
president the streets of the Middle East
in Baghdad in Beirut in Tehran and other
cities I have witnessed large
demonstrations which in all countries
are still ongoing events are unfolding
and each case is different yet there
seem to be some common causes the
triggers have been specific policy
initiatives but the protests have then
expanded targeting inequality
sectarianism and corruption and asking
for better governance and better job
opportunities our response to these
protests has common elements too we have
condemned any act of violence from all
parties we have urged restraint in
handling the demonstrations we have
asked for respect for freedom of
expression and prompt investigation of
instances of violence we've also
demanded that external actors always
respect this country's sovereignty now
let me briefly comment on a few specific
cases the ones you mentioned on the
title of the debate first on Iraq the
challenges that Iraq is facing are
unique the country is finally coming out
of a long conflict
it needs reconciliation and
reconstruction it also needs to deliver
on its people's aspirations to a better
life and better opportunities for all
these expectations need to be fulfilled
if it
is to sub you lies in the long-term and
I've seen myself during my last visit
there in July if I'm not wrong how far
the country has gone when it comes to
being ready to work on reconciliation
and construction but also how fragile
this progress is and I think we are now
seeing this clear from the beginning of
the protests we asked for dialogue and
steps to quickly address the protesters
concerns including those steps suggested
by the UN mission this is even more
urgent today we also continue to
encourage Iraq to maintain its policy of
constructive engagement with all its
neighbors in times when its role as a
voice of wisdom is essential in the
region we Europeans have always said
that we want to help the people of Iraq
win the peace and this is what the
people of Iraq are asking right now so
we will continue to be on their side and
to accompany rock on its path towards a
stronger more inclusive and more just
democracy in Iran the recent protests
also stem from genuine frustration with
the current economic hardships citizens
have the right to peaceful demonstrates
and there is no justification for the
disproportionate use of violence by the
security forces all reports of incidents
the serve Swift and full investigation
by the relevant independent authorities
I also want to emphasize that we expect
the Iranian authorities to ensure the
free flow of information and access to
the Internet at all times let me add
something that is clear and obvious but
it's important to clarify this once
again this has nothing to do and should
have nothing to do with the
implementation of the nuclear deal with
Iran we continue to fully believe in the
diplomatic and security value of the
jcpoa of the nuclear deal with with iran
yet there's no secrets that the
preservation of this agreement has
become increasingly difficult and let me
announce today that we will have a Joint
Commission with Iran that will be
conveyed deputies level on December the
6th to descend as you know together with
there all of High Representative also
comes the role of a coordinator
the Joint Commission of the jcpoa of the
nuclear deal with Iran and we have
worked in this capacity so far very hard
to keep the unity and not only of the
Europeans that has been done but also of
the participants to the nuclear deal
that have remained in the agreement
after the u.s. withdrew and I believe
this unity is key to preserve the
agreement as much as possible
we all agreed just a few weeks ago that
we must spare no energy to preserve the
deal and let me also say that I wish my
successor all the best as he takes over
also this difficult essential role that
are coordinating the Joint Commission of
the jcpoa third and last but not least
at all let me say a few words on Lebanon
where protests have led to the Prime
Minister's resignation Lebanon is a very
special partner for the European Union
and it holds a very special place in our
hearts today the people of Lebanon are
asking for good governance good
governance and good governance beyond
any sectarian line and this is truly
inspiring as Lebanon society often is it
is urgent to address the demands of the
Lebanese people while preserving the
peace and the stability that Lebanon has
so hardly achieved in all these years
this calls first and foremost for the
Swift formation of a functioning
government to ensure political and
economic stability followed by the rapid
and decisive implementation of effective
reforms on governance and corruption in
line with the Lebanese people's
aspiration this moment can become
somehow an opportunity to deliver the
reforms that Lebanon so urgently needs
while at the same time preserving the
country's stability and resilience and
let me add one words on something that
is not on our focus specifically tonight
but it's still there let us not forget
that the whole Middle East remains an
incredibly fragile place we just
discussed the situation in Israel and
Palestine let us not forget that the
situation in Syria is still far from
being settled on the contrary
in the northwest of Syria the situation
has got worse once again only a few
weeks after the Turkish military
operation opened a new front in the
northeast of Syria so regional tensions
are still running high and this is
putting even more importance and
pressure on those in the region and
beyond the region that are trying to
calm down the situation and find
sustainable outcomes to the current
dynamics in these years we've been
trying to build multilateral solutions
to all crises in the region and we have
worked very closely with our partners
including Lebanon and Iraq to stabilize
those countries to bring investment for
Reconstruction and economic growth and
to support these countries in their
reform agendas each of these countries
will have to find its own way to
overcome their current difficulties
nobody can do it for them but the
European Union will continue I believe
to support dialogue and accompany
reforms it is one of the regions that
are closest to us I often say it's our
common region and the European Union I
believe will continue to engage as a
reliable partner and as a force for
peace in the Middle East thank you